What do catastrophic floods, extratropical
cyclones, debilitating drought, and a massive
oyster die-off have in common?
Rivers in the sky.
No, really.
Hey waterbabies, it’s Natalia for DNews!
California is currently in the middle of a
relentless drought, but it might be alleviated
with a super interesting weather phenomena
called atmospheric rivers -- those rivers
in the sky I was telling you about.
Atmospheric rivers, or ARs, deliver the bulk
of the precipitation to the state -- on average,
each one delivers at least one Mississippi
river’s worth of rain -- and they actually
occur around the the world.
ARs form in the tropics when winds from a
cyclone draw moisture into long, narrow bands
that move ahead of a cold front.
In their wake, they often bring winds that
can rival hurricane speeds.
ARs usually arrive in 4-5 separate plumes
of moisture that are, on average, 2000 kilometers
in length and up to 1000 kilometers in width.
Because they can bring such monumental amounts
of precipitation, they can cause devastating
floods, landslides, and even snowstorms when
they reach the mountains.
In California, this rain and snowfall is actually
vital to the state.
A whopping 30-50% of California’s annual
precipitation is made up of just a few of
these atmospheric rivers.
And all 7 floods in the state’s Russian
River from 1997 to 2006 were caused by atmospheric
rivers.
They are truly a blessing and a curse!
In fact, California has suffered through many
AR floods.
In 1861, a flood hit the state that killed
thousands of people and drowned 800,000 cattle.
In 2005 the small coastal town of La Conchita
was in the path of an AR that caused a massive
landslide that killed 10 people.
And these events and floods are not new developments.
Research of geologic cores show that the region
has been hit by megastorms causing catastrophic
floods every 200 years.
But it wasn’t until the 1990s, with the
advent of new satellite technology, that scientists
could truly understand and track these ‘sky
rivers’.
Sidebar -- ARs are also called “the Pineapple
Express,” a term that was coined by newscasters
in the 1960s after they noticed these recurring,
excessively wet weather events coming from
Hawaii.
Just so you know.
New research shows that climate change could
make these ARs even more dangerous, as there
will be increased evaporation of water due
to higher temperatures, leading to larger
ARs.
Some scientists say they may even cause cataclysmic,
extinction level floods.
But ARs are not exclusive to California.
There are 7 to 12 ARs present around the world
at any given time!
There are instances of ARs in the middle of
the United States, North Africa, and Western
Europe.
In fact, in 2015, a monster AR spanning over
8,000 kilometers accompanied Storm Desmond
that caused flooding in the United Kingdom,
Ireland, and Norway.
And according to scientists, they have been
increasing in frequency in Western Europe
in recent years.
Aside from crazy weather, ARs can also have
secondary consequences, like killing off oysters.
In 2011, there was a massive wild Olympia
oyster die-off in Northern California.
Scientists found that these oysters were sensitive
to low salinity levels caused by excess freshwater
from the 20 ARs that passed through the region
between October 2010 and September 2011.
Although our research couldn’t find any
immediate implications for other sea life,
it will be interesting to see what other marine
animals may be affected by an increased frequency
of ARs.
If you like life or death situations, you
might get hooked watching Deadliest Catch
on the Discovery Channel!
Now you can watch that and all your favorite
Discovery Channel Shows on the Discovery Go
app!
Download for free at your app store or look
at the link below to learn more!
So, California is still in a drought -- and
that drought is affecting the rest of the
world.
Find out how, here.
And what do you think?
Have you been affected by AR events?
Tell us in the comments below.
And thanks for watching DNews!
Subscribe and come back every day for new
episodes.